it's not normal it's not a normal thing
to see but it's a normal thing to do
because I know we all do it at home
every single one of us we all dance our
own nak
it the bun cheese have been
[Music]
auring what happened to you my daddy
discovered the Ping situation oh Jesus
Dominic you poor thing yeah what the
hell was he hitting you with a kettle
was the final thing I I wouldn't mind
for the bo yeah it's Mar McD's first
movie in Ireland isn't it and it's a
piece of history there I think just
having out just whole Irish crew cast
Irish crews are amazing they just go
yeah that's that yep y we got it yeah
and it's just like short and sweet
Dominic reminded me of there was a
character Mar McDonald's play called
Bartley the of inish man kind of
reminded me of he's ER what he K great
there's a bit of there's a bit of that
going on as well like he's there's a lot
um a lot of characters I could pull from
maybe this whole thing is just been
about getting you to try a new tack
start standing up for yourself a bit do
you think yeah and be less of a you know
WHYY little dollar you know there's no
really takes that we do the same thing
and that again is just down to being
comfy with one another and so that has
its advantages and then it has it
disadvantages when you live with them
and like you get too comfy with them
it's like that thing of lift up the
toilet SE
you know that them kind of little things
yeah like who left the fridge door open
I like it's not me I was like you're the
only one here yeah no I didn't think
so just thought I'd asking the off
chance you know like fin heart
nut there goes that
dream there goes that
dream oh my man it's funny because that
take I was like rushing off to catch a
plane I was like we got it I was like
let me you know let me just you know I
was like trying to go go and get an
answer give me the answer okay well
anyways and that was the last take of
the movie as well for me well that's a
it's a credit to Mar mcon he's he's one
of the best Royers out
there the killing of a sacred
[Music]
there hi hi
sorry to keep you waiting all right did
you eat I just had some apple pie do you
mind if I go grab something to eat
before we go I'm starving Martin what a
name Martin he's such a weird little
freak kid that's a freakest character I
think I played you know cuz I don't know
if he had like a superow or some stuff
like
that uh which I I never found out but I
remember Colin saying you're going to
probably play The Joker one day after
this character remember him saying that
to me and though Hotel he like this is
one of the most evst villains You'll
Play The Joker one day after this I
think she I think she likes you I mean
she's attracted to you but she says
that's not true but it is I'm
sure and to be honest I think you're
perfect for each
other you'd make a great couple he
doesn't really ask to keep it monotone
or anything like that but I remember he
did say stop acting I was all right I'll
get it I'll get it now cuz jorus wants a
certain way he wants his dialogue
delivered and can't really animate her
or put any color on her really you kind
of have to strip it all back but he has
his way he has his method and it works
and I'm always up for going along with
trying new
[Music]
stuff
saltor actually understand and here he
is no we were just talking about you
don't be silly Marley you just make up
the most awful things of course we
weren't hello Oliver darling that I had
a lot of fun with because we want to
trick the audience into thinking he's
sweet and then it's in know what's his
motive and and then just turns Emerald I
mean she's an amazing person first of
all I was checking on everyone making
sure her set is good and the energy is
good so you have kind of a safeness to
to Ram about as the character oh she
loves all of it she's like I love them I
had five notebooks for that five M skin
notebooks instead of like one or two
each notebook would represent
personalities you know different
acceleration different motives different
tone how is he different from here to
Oliver tree just reminding you you know
not too too much either you don't want a
whole Bible of it because you go in and
you're just stiff then I think you know
you just have to have a looseness about
it and just I know where to go just
taking these back to the
library take my
bike no no no I couldn't I mean I mean
it looks like rain I wouldn't I wouldn't
want honestly it's no a big deal I mean
I'll just get it from you later you're
my college so am
I yeah with Jacob I was just you know
getting used and used to them and just
hanging out with them but they were
staying elsewhere while I was staying
here no I got my baby here my baby boy I
was uh making hot milk and changing
nappies and they were at this hotel and
they were just hanging out a lot so I
kind of felt left out so I like I'm
going getes you
know in the movie obviously I'm a
getes I've to scen is he's submitting to
this Obsession and trying to figure out
what it is he's chasing and you know
almost like a sacrifice and how he
lowers himself into the bath you know
physically and then when he gets down
there he's just um confused and helpless
and
sick you know to do
that G but you can't judge that as as
you play him I can judge it as a
spectator but when I'm playing him I got
to see Justice to it and see that it's
the right thing to
do the grave scene the same thing I just
wanted to to explore and grow with the
character and figure them out and see
when you know I ask for a I was set I
said I want to try something and I just
wanted to see what I'd do as Oliver when
action happened and where I went and to
me he just went to a place of you know
being totally heartbroken and lost and
confused that's where the books helped
me out because it remind me of where I'm
at and how to feel basically what mood
to be in it was totally improv that it
was crazy I just said Play the music
I'll do it n that was choreographed by
Polly Bennett she's brilliant you know
you got to hit some steps and I think
was gorgeous to look at a a figure like
that Roman you know that that manner you
know dripping in money and paintings
from the 1700s and you know to move so
freely it's not normal it's not a normal
thing to see but it's a normal thing to
do because I know we all do it at home
every single one of us we all dance own
nak it so it's probably the most
relatable scene in the movie um to
everyone
[Music]
watching eternals when I
left I thought about taking over the
minds of every human on this
planet
violence fear greed all gone he mind
controls everything so I'd love to see
him be just a movie of him playing about
mind control and everyone no really
motive just mind mind controling for the
sake of it prep for that is you're doing
superhero movie so you got to humaniz
them don't play the superhero try to
bring the The Human Side of the out
Chloe just kind of let me be me and
wanted me to kind of be still and Chloe
kept referencing Hayden Christensen his
character in Star Wars to be a bit more
she just wanted me to be a bit more
still very chin high and that was the
only really prep I kind of done was was
to learn to walk a bit slower and I
tried to mind control people and people
like what are you doing why are you
staring at
me the green
[Music]
light who are
you this a traveler friend you look like
a
knight this passing
through ah I take you you want some of
the share so huh of
what all of
this
do you know what the scavenger reminds
me of sort of like the the kind of a an
arel Dodger kind of character you know
he's got a trick up a sleeve or you know
he's a he's a tager long that long shot
was my boots kept coming off cuz it was
in the mud you know we had to get it
where I walked through and it was one
shot obviously as well which is really
you to kind of finish all the dialogue
you know up until a certain point but my
shoes kept coming off so I'd end up at
the end of the day no shoes
on TWR off just TWR
off TWR enough anything I don't kind of
freak Dev out anything
um so I could say anything or do
anything you know I Haven the the booked
teeth as well and yeah I just it added a
lot to the character um just I could
play around being my own accent as well
you kind of have a bit more freedom to
improve and the coin was really useful I
did another layer to him that trickery
thing to him and then the axe was just I
mean that's what the whole movie is
about isn't it but yeah you can really
play around with props I love getting a
prop it's almost a little character of
itself isn't
it
Dunkirk Dunkirk that was a massive
moment I mean just the set and what
Chris Nolan does on you know on the
water he's got real planes
coming towards it that take a half an
hour to to reset you don't really need
to act I remember the plane coming
towards me and so just zoned in on the
plane I was like oh my God and he was
like tell him to get lower and the plane
was getting lower then towards our boat
I remember then looking at going
man and then he was rolling he's said
we're rolling I was like oh like
half an hour to reset turn it
around turn
it calm it down
mate calm it down mate
the fight with me and my fellow Irish
man Kil morphy yeah he wouldn't do that
in real life but anyways not
mey n that was quite tricky I mean
because when I fell back I had to kind
of duck my head as well so I didn't
really fcking hit my head and go blind
poor George killing the sweater that
little te teac cozy sweater do you
remember that that was a statement that
I wanted more with Killian though I
wanted to do more me him and Chris we
just cuz Chris has you know some
orangish relatives and that we we just
chatting about Ireland and stuff like
that and where's the best Guinness in
Dublin
and the
Batman have you read this
file you two have so much in
common mask
aventures originally there was no
audition I just made myself an audition
type cuz I seen an article saying that
the they wanted uh the Riddler and the
new Batman I was like oh yeah I'd love
to play that I just made a tape I said f
I'mma buy a cane and a hat just find
myself a corridor and film myself
walking down it add some like little bit
of a swag to it and bit of music and
let's see will that get me an audition
so I done that yeah and they said
no what you want to play The Joker I was
like yep I
think you don't really care about his
motives with he love so I hate you that
took 6 hours to to to get into that and
I was like oh man I couldn't sit still
for 6 hours I really couldn't and then I
remember we're on 5 hours and then
someone came in went we shut in
production on it was Co I was I was like
huh really what what happened there was
like the steel thing on my ground that
was like slicing in I was I'm really
going to be left with a scar here so I
was like that and Rob was in the bath
suit and I'm like ha and he's like ha ha
I'm like know ha you we couldn't move we
literally couldn't get up and move I was
looking at pictures of asylums and I
remember seeing this thing on the in
this Asylum picture and I always saved
on my phone and around the Batman like
the Joker and I said spray paint of an
old Asylum room and I said hell was more
fun I was like wo like that is
crazy